so Bob what did you decide on us I am
definitely not a barrel no you're lying
but still I'm cringing at the thought oh
wait I think you're just gonna Chuck a
grenade somewhere the first barrel in
front of you because it was supposed to
go all right fine you were an idiot but
I'm actually gonna try to do something
here okay well then and I can't get out
ghost hunters until we can find you be
thorough make sure everything's tipped
over if we tip over everything
you can't possibly a this happened no I
did but yes I'm so stuck in the barrel
my god mark that's right next to you how
did you not see me I ran away if you see
how there's suddenly a barrel not next
to you no I don't I'm gonna go with
these lie or you ran away we've got no
hope cuz everything's a barrel
we got the silent
over yonder way wherever he is pilot
barrel in a room full of barrels okay I
think the only way that we can do this
is Wade we need to walk back Bob zombie
is in the dark far away from so far away
from you right now oh oh who is that is
that Wade oh very observant if you not
see that barrel fly in your face
no he's throwing barrels at you
all right I just act natural no one will
ever your go stage what to do no I want
to duel you okay no no it's I want to do
it okay alright I'll play your game
play your game this is my fight this is
my place wait this is my fight I'm
trying to come out on stuck on some
stuff Oh God
Oh weights not messing around Oh God
wait it's impossible just give up what
they're getting confident they'll make a
mistake we just got to be very careful
if we miss one shot they were ghosts
right in front of us and we miss we're
dead why can't I see okay oh I started
in the don't touch a barrel don't touch
a barrel don't touch anything
barks in paranoid anything don't touch
anything
yeah don't touch anything did you knock
over that barrel yes okay don't touch
anything I think we've established that
hi-de-ho disturbed ours over the
underway
I'm like crazy what the hell's going on
disturbed barrels I guess he's not gonna
answer me
so huh what Bob huh I see something over
there something we were in the darkness
I'm looking go that way all right once
again if you're hiding in the darkness
it's totally unfair
Oh is he moving and we can't see again
they're like just outside of where we're
able to see you may think we can see you
but we cannot it's not fair you're
cheating who did that who's digging with
me who did that
why are you guys so silent right now I'm
just gonna say you don't deserve a hint
why I know someone's messing with me no
mark no mark mark mark no no no no no no
no you are standing on me are you lying
right now are you actually being honest
I was really where it is I don't care
don't care anymore okay be very clear
was i standing on you yeah what when you
move to when that one barrel flew out of
nowhere and hit you you moved on to me
and I almost lost my [ __ ] completely you
no no no you want me to kill you oh
here's what you deserve
you get to wait two minutes while we do
nothing that's what you get to do
trolling it's awful what no it's
trolling me I know they're in front of
me it's aware of what's happening yeah
blade you [ __ ]
I know you're aware but we're gonna be
hunters again don't care anymore
oh this is our life now this is gonna be
the worst two minutes of footage ever
hey I can fast-forward gonna oh my god
you're getting back where is on my head
yeah kinda it's very good I only have 55
health I don't know now you do oh I
swear those are like 200 health barrels
it's not 30 seconds of waiting to find a
barrel it's not fair
you guys can't hide in the darkness you
really can't that is totally unfair
zombie zombie zombie is a cheating
cheater cheating cheater I don't play
with cheating cheaters this whole map is
a cheating cheater wait is totally fair
if you're not bad like you if you're
done like me oh yeah oh yeah how many
kills have you got no yeah none wait a
minute what's up who did this but I was
totally there when you that was how
that's how the map what did this nothing
happened I was a barrel doctor over over
here good there's the couple over he is
a barrel oddly placed over here why was
this just floating in mid-air who was
holding it what are you well that's one
down
and all of a sudden Bob got quiet
because he's gonna be a hunter next hey
wait you found marks barrel Castle I
made it for him
I look barrel didn't hurt the first time
I shot it Wow way to be stupid wait I'm
not in the darkness
oh so wait you were hitting the right
one you just it's your punishment for
everything Marge what we've suffered
years off my life because of this I
never want to be on Barsoom again that
had one in the middle there that's
running got it
zombie down nice you know goes I assumed
it wait I saw something glittering in
the darkness I think I saw glint on us
in a glasses I'm pretty sure that's what
I saw
if I shoot at the ground does it
illuminate where I am no okay no that's
stupid
it's so dark I'm right on the edge I can
see me you can see you saying you can't
see me moving around right in front of
you oh all right let me scooch out
slowly and we'll see where the darkness
ends okay I see a barrel it just ran out
that's not actually a ghost
barrel but he was a ghost I'm pretty
just behind you mark you ran out that
way okay
I would never we were testing the limit
you were just using that to distract me
weren't you Bob
maybe you dick we're gonna get at least
just how many how many rounds are left
fountain alright oh my god we've been
hunters for like an hour
we're not gonna play their game we're
gonna go out the way we want to go out I
wish I could talk to zombie cuz I think
we just did exactly the same thing and I
think it's beautiful
I think whatever beauty it may be will
be wasted and what the get on top of a
barrel I spawned on top of the barrels
all right on top I see you over there
gotcha oh that might also be why you you
losers suck I still think that we're
probably the winners in this whole
situation
nah the comments rate comments will
clearly favor us because you guys are
giant douches it was totally your fault
zombie runs the server we possibly well
yeah Sam B doesn't run the server listen
by zombie zombie did you or did you not
change it from switching teams your
silence is it Oh
[Music]
sound of my death